>> Welcome back everyone Brian
kilmeade show with me in studio
if you're watching FOX nation
you see it empty boat so great
to see him in person, your book
is excellent mission possible
go create a life
that counts. Baseball play
football player has been Trophy
winner now broadcast, but we're
not necessarily talking about
that before we get into the
heart of
the book, your reaction to
Russell Wilson be going to the
Broncos honestly I I got to say
I'm kind of excited about it I
still.
I think I'm a little
bit biased but I just think
Bronco fans are awesome I can't
tell you how much I loved my
time there and.
>> I think you didn't want to
play of the second less yeah
and then we lost the her but
it was.
>> Such a special couple of
years being there with the
Bronco fans and I still love
them to be honest with you I
think they're incredible fans I
think Russell going there I
think it's going to bring a lot
of life I think they have a lot
of talent there I think they're
going to be really good
and also I'm excited about the
division that's going to be
crazy. Good like are you
kidding you have that sees I
think I the Raiders are going
to be a lot better.
You know Josh there now that's
going to be fascinating and it
to drafted NATO and so that's
going to be really interesting
and then you know the Chargers
obviously I've gotten so much
better so right pretty
interesting didn't bring in
Peyton Manning you think that
was your job.
Did you know the last one
started before you start to
look back and say you know what
if I would just say that I
think it was so special such a
special time I think that we
are able to do some really
special things in specially
from being one in 4 and then to
go on a run and
and when the division and then
he'd tie tell of
it was really special and if
you know you never know maybe
if we had more time could a
dense a special
things but also they brought in
someone County get paid in
pretty good hands up in Yeah
pretty good yeah after taking a
year and a half off or
something. Suzanne I mean the
intro to your book and by the
way I loved you had to write
about, but you got a lot of
success you like, but you don't
pull punches when it doesn't
work I remember you writing
about you you play for the
Patriots, you hit it off with
Belichick Bob Kraft invited to
the House, you expect to go
over there for
a party, and like so they go to
money to see you gave up a
commercial yeah dollars yes
because you said hey bill do
you mind if I do this you I got
up really would like any coach
in the next day
or so.
>> Haha I know, but like I kind
of got my hopes that was it was
Mister Kraft uh-uh come over
the House were having the
luncheon and
some like I mean I guess it
that he came from and as they
love not so fast. My brand
happens you're fired.
So a football player or
baseball player broadcaster,
and he said finding mission,
I'm thinking of myself on
surfaced.
>> Okay that's his mission.
He found broadcasting after
because that's what it that's
what I do for a living is
right, but you found a mission
and your mission happened to
you because you saw the tragedy
in front of you. Yes,
and that tragedy was this
little boy with to feed born on
backwards yes, nothing to do
with his fall that his fault,
yes, but his life was
was almost over before was is
because he was viewed as a
throwaway because where he
lived they they viewed him as
cursed is less than it is in
significant.
>> And really the only reason
that he was able to survive was
because he had 2 friends that
we're willing to do whatever
it.
Took to to fight to get him
food literally steal food to to
put it on his his his his table
his plate to give him food and
he was viewed as this throw
away. And I just knew that it
wasn't a throwaway to God and
he should be a throwaway to me
or anybody else and we need to
I personally knew that day I
was called to go fight for boys
and girls like him around the
world and and you would you is
that that was when I was 15
years old. And you know who you
are that nobody.
it was something that I knew
that was my mission I didn't
know exactly what look like I
didn't know exactly what I was
supposed to do, but I knew it
was around this it was based on
this and I think there's
probably a lot of people that
or think of all what exactly is
my mission I've never had that
encounter
and I would say yeah I don't
know exactly what your mission
is but have your eyes ever been
open to a need to a problem to
a hurting person and has your
heart ever been pricked to want
to go do something if so that
that might be got saying, hey
we'll start to meet this need
and you might not know exactly
what it looks like you know, I
know exactly the end goal or
how the twists and the turns in
it, but it's got to also start
with action. Right and I
believe that that when we see
this and we feel this we need
to act and it will
you know, it's also living by
faith you don't know exactly
what all the next steps are but
we have to take the step in and
being able and willing to go do
something and we'll continue to
learn in the process, what was
the foundation that started
then and how's your mission
even brought you to the war in
Ukraine well I'll tell you that
if I wasn't a lot of started NC
double a rules until I College
and then was literally the
first or second day after I
graduated.
>> Was when I started it into a
foundation and our mission
statement was literally just
thinking about that boys one of
the easiest things I did.
Okay, what is our mission
statement I thought about him I
said OK.
It's the brink faith hope and
love to those needing a
brighter day and their darkest
hour of need because that what
is that boy in need.
He needs faith hope and love
because he is in his darkest
hour of need. He is a throwaway
and he needs help and he
urgently needs help.
And so that was our mission
statement and it started with
orphans and it started with
special needs and then we let
into hospitals and then
ultimately lead to more in the
fight against human trafficking
a growing and growing and.
And it's been something that
has developed in developed
throughout the years because we
didn't know first what it
looked like, but guys continue
to show us as we've gone and
now the Ukraine war starts
United bystander what are you
doing
we have been able to serve in
the Ukraine for for several
years, especially or night to
shine host churches was night
to shine is a worldwide problem
for people with special needs
and there's been many churches
in Ukraine that have hosted in
partnered with us and that and
loving the special needs
community.
>> And you know when all of
this happened and we're
communicating with our host
churches and I was partners
that take care of or offense
and special needs kids is what
do you what do you need how can
we help how can we support and
I'll tell you
that we think that that that
we're supporting and maybe we
are a little bit but I'll tell
you they're inspiring us more
than we could ever do for them.
The heroes that
we have that we have seen that
we have talked to that we have
partnered with that we have
watched they're not everyday
hero and they're great right
here this is craker AC courage.
It is incredible to watch, I
mean the.
You know because of the time
difference our team's getting
up super early in the middle of
the night to talk to them first
thing in the morning so they
can figure out the day what do
they need how can we support
how going get him to safety and
then working with you know
different like life's on and
trying to get safe homes ready
and Poland's a different way
where the roads are so many
different things we're grateful
for so many partners that are
working on different parts of
this but.
>> But what what they say is
hey you know, we know bombs are
going off around us, but we
know God's in control and this
is exactly we're supposed to be
in so many of had the chance
when they've taken groups out
to stay out.
And yet so many of our partners
go right back in to serve and
to continue to help
and I'll tell you what it
really is true courage in true
hero Tim tebow's book is called
mission possible people want to
help you with the foundation
and find out their mission
where they go Foundation that
or Dodge it now.
>> win
the Heisman. Sophomore right,
yes, awfully win the Heisman
sophomore UK you win a playoff
game shocked the world beat the
Pittsburgh Steelers.
You for 2 years you making way
the minor leagues you almost
made as a tight end in this
league too you've an believe
success international fame.
How does that compare.
To this what you're doing with
your Foundation has that
success in sports compare it
doesn't compare not at all
doesn't mean anything.
I think the
thing that the world is going
to tell us and it has and even
at times I bought into it
unfortunately is that.
>> We need to strive for money
fame and power. And that it's
going to be a rewarding in the
more of that
you get the the more identity,
the stronger identity them the
more you're going to have and I
just don't believe it I think
God's economy is different.
I believe the more you give the
more you actually have
and I've seen that with so many
of our partners around the
world we just got back from
from Africa we were for for a
month and you see it with so
many people that that.
Materially don't
have much but spiritually
emotionally relation. Lee.
They have everything because of
what they're doing every day
and I'll tell you what those
are also heroes of mine.
So you took your fame in your
power and use it for other
people well I think what I've
really would love to do a
strive to do is take the little
bit of success that
they got has blessed me with
and turning that success into
significance because I believe
success is about us. But
significance is about other
people and I would rather have
a life of significance to life
a success because I believe
there's going to be a lot of
people that at the end of their
life. They had a lot of success
and then they realize
it doesn't mean anything and I
don't want to be someone that
the you know my life I have I
have a little bit of success
and I realize.
Oh my gosh it's really a
tragedy because none of it
matters you just so like a
million books because that'